we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman hydrant
is the delicious fruit drink powder
packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost effective than expensive sugary
sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
you know it's very interesting how
here in the united states when it comes
to the virus and in particular when it
comes to
vaccines which we will be talking about
significantly
really starting now and expecting
approval of vaccines in the u.s
potentially even within hours or in the
next few days
into 2021 within this area of
vaccination
and really with the virus in general
reality
is increasingly the exact opposite of
what the trump administration tells us
that it is
and this has to some degree been the
case for a while now but it's
increasingly glaring and we can
sort of go back to the beginning as far
as vaccines are concerned
and remember that for months donald
trump and this administration have been
telling us that
his vaccine initiative called operation
warp speed
is the only way to get vaccines
ready quickly that without operation
warp speed vaccines could take
five to six years to get as he said in
that
clip i played for you yesterday from
tuesday's vaccine summit
it used to take infinity to get a
vaccine
whatever that means until operation warp
speed which is a strange thing
to say uh but the truth is is very
different the truth has been
and continues to be that the reason
we're getting vaccines for coronavirus
relatively quickly
is that the ones we're seeing now pfizer
bioentech
oxford astrazeneca moderna they're built
on an mrna platform this is much faster
to work with much faster to develop
than the traditional vaccines which are
based on weakened or
dead virus and we also have those coming
this is an important thing to remember
in 2021 we're expecting
there will be new coronavirus vaccines
as well uh based
on that weakened or dead virus platform
those are under development they still
take longer
operation warp speed has not accelerated
those in any way either
and of course donald trump's claims
never passed the sniff test because the
vaccine development that was happening
in other countries
was taking place just as quickly as in
the united states and of course the
development for example in the uk
of the oxford vaccine had nothing to do
with operation warp speed and you don't
even need to look at other countries
because even within the united states
the vaccination development under the
mrna platform
by companies not taking operation warp
speed money
happened just as quickly as those who
did take operation warp speed money so
it
it was very clear that this wasn't
passing the sniff test
and fascinatingly this has now come to
be flipped on its head
because despite trump's bragging about
operation warp speed
being the one and only sole path to
developing a vaccine quickly
both the united kingdom and canada have
beaten the united states
to approved coronavirus vaccines earlier
this week i told you that the united
kingdom approved
its vaccine and is already vaccinating
people its vaccine
they approved the pfizer bioentec
vaccine originally developed in germany
they are already vaccinating people
there are now concerns about
uh allergic reactions which are still
early and we're exploring whether there
are folks with with prior
allergic reactions to vaccines who maybe
should not get this one
very early but they're starting to build
that data starting to vaccinate
people now it's canada as well canada's
health department yesterday gave
emergency approval
for the pfizer bioentech vaccine so
it's no longer rhetoric trump has been
bragging for months about imaginary
accomplishments on vaccines
we had the sense that the bragging was
not based in fact
now today december 10 2020
the united kingdom has an approved
coronavirus vaccine and is vaccinating
people
canada has an approved coronavirus
vaccine
and will have vaccinations happening
within the within days
and the us does not yet have an approved
coronavirus vaccine
now it should be just a matter of days
or even hours the fda
panel meeting is already happening i was
watching some of it earlier today
during this meeting at its conclusion
they are going to be voting as to
whether to grant emergency use
authorization
for the pfizer bioentec vaccine i
believe it's december
17th a week from today that we will uh
have a meeting of the fda
about emergency use authorization for
the moderna vaccine so in 10 days we
could have two approved vaccines right
now we do not
um and and so the question is why does
our guy constantly brag
but get out done in the end on the facts
humility seems not to be an option
particularly when he ends up getting
embarrassed by the facts every time
he just comes up with more lies and
remember that donald trump and his
administration promised us
300 million vaccine doses in 2020.
you you it's hard to keep track because
they constantly move the goalposts but
the promise was
300 million doses by the end of 2020
they failed plain and simple
and now unfortunately and and i don't
take any pleasure in this
because of donald trump opting out of
securing an additional hundred thousand
pfizer bioentectosis when given the
option in late summer
uh we are going to be at a deficit in
terms of being able to really get people
vaccinated so
updated timeline a first vaccine
expected to be approved in the next
hours or days second vaccine december
17th
meeting assuming both get approved we
are looking at vaccination
for about 20 million people in the next
few weeks
now remember there is this 28 day period
from when you get your first dose to
when you have the full power of the
vaccine
a dose one tends to get you
you know somewhere between 60 and 80
percent uh
immunity success dose 2
gets you to the 95 seven days after that
second dose has been
has been received so by february 1st
we may have six or so percent of the
facts of the population immune remember
the vaccinations will start sooner
but it takes a while to build the
immunity uh and it's a start
the u.s recently has been averaging more
than 200 000 cases per day remember dr
fauci told us months ago
you know we could get if we're not
careful we could get to 100k per day
half the country said no no no now we're
at 200 000 cases per day
and deaths meanwhile tragically continue
to soar
i told you we could be close to a 911's
worth of
deaths every day but now we are there
several days this week between 2 900 and
3 000 deaths
per day in the united states
inconceivably tragic
by the way people still just don't even
get what's going on
even in massachusetts yesterday i left a
bakery
required to wear a mask so i did uh got
my croissants
and as i was walking out with my mask a
maskless guy walks by me i tweeted about
this and says
pathetic masks wearing a blue lives
matter shirt by the just as a detail
also wearing a blue lives matter shirt
this guy so
we have a lot of people who still don't
even get it now as far as vaccines go
the big tragedy is the death and the
human and economic cost as a result of
the missteps and also we can't forget
the missteps at every opportunity by the
administration
it started with denying the seriousness
of the pandemic they refused to wear
masks until much too late
trump turned down the 100 million doses
of the pfizer vaccine
from uh pfizer over the summer now we're
not going to get our second delivery of
pfizer vaccines
potentially until june of 2021. they
failed on the second stimulus they were
regularly outdone in terms of stimulus
by
uh um other countries um
other wealthy countries oecd countries
doing better both in terms of
suppressing and
in terms of stimulus so it's sad it's
tragic it's pathetic i don't know what
the right word is sort of in all of the
above
but if there is any optimistic news
it's that we're starting to get the
vaccines and soon trump will be gone and
we will have something a little more
sensible
um guiding us through this a hugely
controversial decision has been made by
youtube
owned by google of course that they will
be straight up removing
any videos which claim that donald trump
lost the election because of so-called
voter fraud which doesn't exist
utah you youtube not utah youtube
is essentially saying joe biden won the
2020 election that's a historical
fact at this point and claims to the
contrary
will fall under the umbrella of
misleading videos which are
and can be restricted on youtube youtube
explains
now that enough states have certified
their elections
such that in total joe biden has 270
electoral votes
they will remove content that quote
misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or errors
change the outcome of the 2020
presidential election now they're not
going to go and do this retroactively so
if you uploaded videos before yesterday
saying
trump won because of voter fraud those
will be allowed to stay up
this is a decision that will go forward
from yesterday
youtube explaining the decision in a
series of tweets let's take a look
youtube saying our goal this election
was to connect people to authoritative
info limit harmful misinformation and
remove violative content
subsequently authoritative news was
widely watched and recommended
and since september we removed more than
8 000 channels for violating our
policies
yesterday was the safe harbor deadline
now that enough states certified their
presidential election results
we'll remove any content published today
or anytime after
that alleges widespread fraud or errors
changed the 2020 u.s presidential
outcome now
that's there's a couple interesting
things there number one
it sounds like they're saying if you are
reporting about an individual instance
of of a clerical error or or fraud or
whatever
that will be allowed but big picture
saying trump really won but because a
voter fraud biden got it that's what
wouldn't be allowed
and the justification they're giving is
that joe biden's win
is now simple empirical undeniable fact
youtube going on to explain quote we'll
also update today our election results
info panel
which already surfaced under 200 000
vids and was shown
more than 4.5 billion times i it'll note
the u.s presidential res
results are certified and linked to the
2020 electoral college results page by
the office of the federal register
lastly saying there's always more to do
striking the balance between openness
and responsibility
is one of our toughest challenges we're
continuing to make improvements
and we'll apply our learnings from this
election globally
i'm actually unsure about the the
long-term effect of this policy and i'll
explain
in the sense that i think youtube might
make life difficult
for themselves with this decision so i
am 100
in agreement that this is completely
within youtube's rights as a business
i'm taking no issue with that whatsoever
youtube is doing nothing
illegal here period i think the
implementation of this is complex
because of the doors that it opens fact
boxes for election content with the
results that say joe biden won and it's
been certified by states
i'm with it 100 even demonetization of
misleading videos which are effectively
conspiracy theories
i would even be okay with that flagging
content
like twitter does as disinformation or
disputed
often when trump tweets i won absolutely
fine
but the complexity is they allow
flat earth content they allow all sorts
of other conspiracy content that is
factually wrong
so now they have to make a distinction
about
what is factually wrong and justifies
removal and here they're saying broad
claims about election fraud
leading to joe biden falsely winning
that has passed a threshold
where it's not a flag it's not sorry i
hit my mic i'm getting so excited
it's not just a flag it's not just
demonetization it's removal now
to be completely clear the trump
actually won stuff
is completely corrosive to democracy
i've been clear and consistent on this
i'm just wondering about the enforcement
of this i might even like where
this goes in the sense that it might
push some of the looney right wing
voices to abandon youtube altogether
and go start their own thing that's
great stop the spread of disinformation
but i do think youtube is opening
themselves up to an
absolute storm of insanity as a result
this is not a censorship issue to me
biden won period youtube can do this
legally 110
but i think the enforcement is going to
be problematic and
and the other thing that i find
interesting is the right wingers are
going
nuts about this and clearly youtube made
the calculation i mean youtube
knew that this was going to be an s
storm when they do it
they calculated stopping the election
conspiracy theories
is worth it to them in exchange
for the criticism that is raining down
upon them from the right
for this decision so uh my concern is
more about implementation and the
precedent that it sets
but we will see ultimately how this
turns out i would love to hear
your thoughts about this decision by
youtube i'm on twitter at deepak
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund
one hundred percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show
depends primarily on folks like you
who get memberships at joinpacman.com so
please consider that
as we head into a new year and a new era
of the show
join pacman.com coupon code available
fresh start saves you a bunch of money
a very interesting discussions this
morning on the david pakman show
subreddit where you can join 26
maybe it's 27 now 26 27 000
other david pakman show viewers
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts you know
i got a few emails like this
and this is a post from portland hipster
who said
david why on earth would you not tell
republicans not to vote in georgia if
you can convince an already
psychologically damaged or duped
republican to not vote for more
destruction
isn't that the morally correct thing to
do in all likelihood having a democratic
controlled senate would benefit these
deranged republicans in material ways so
don't you have a moral obligation to
help get a democratic-controlled senate
by any ethical way possible
doesn't that trump your principle of
voting no i don't think so
what i said earlier this week and last
week is one of the main
one of the big messages the top level
messages
on this show is engaging people in the
political processes
and part of that is increasing voter
turnout and everyone must vote everyone
must vote everyone must vote
and so because that's the big principle
what this user is doing
is engaging in a special pleading which
is well yes
get more people involved vote vote vote
except
this time whereby buying into
obviously false conspiracy theories that
the election is rigged
and abandoning the principle of
increasing engagement
you might serve a greater good right the
argument is well you know
your argument david about more
engagement is generally good
but here democrats taking the senate
would create so much good it would
trickle down
it's justified morally this time
for you to lie to people and say you
know what republicans you're right it's
rigged and you should stay home
the this is exactly one of the points
i've been making
just because i might be able to justify
it in this micro case
i'm not going to abandon the macro
principle and i don't think the left
needs to
i don't think the left you know when i
say guys listen
um i want to change campaign finance but
right now
the candidate that raises the most money
wins and the candidate that buys tv ads
uh is more likely to win we've got to do
it we we can't unilaterally
disarm uh because then we'll just never
win
this is different this is a principle of
engagement and civic duty and voting and
so
i wouldn't feel okay abandoning it here
and saying yeah you guys
the it is rigged you should you should
stay home republicans don't vote i just
wouldn't feel good about it others might
and it's a
decision you'll have to make for
yourselves um user brody mulligan
says if offered to you and available
immediately would you take pfizer's
covid 19 vaccine
you know at this point i would now based
on what i've been seeing um
based on my risk profile and demographic
information
i am not likely to be able to get a
vaccine until april may or june
as of right now if half the country ends
up not wanting it that that might
accelerate and it might be moved up
at this point i have seen enough of the
data and pfizer
bioentech released detailed data um two
days ago about the vaccine
uh that i would take it i know that
there's roughly a a 10
chance that i would have some kind of a
reaction
physical reaction in the arm i'm not
someone who's had prior
uh allergic reactions to vaccines
and so that is not a concern to me and
the data to me
would be if if i wasn't taking it from
anybody who needs it more acutely than i
do today
i would take the pfizer bioentec vaccine
curious to hear from folks in the
audience where you stand about that
you can join the discussion and even
vote in the poll
asking about the pfizer vaccine um
by joining the subreddit it's free i'm
not selling you anything just join the
community
at davidpakman.com reddit
all right um buckle up everybody i'm
about to
be called a racist unfortunately there
are people who are going to listen to
this segment and call me a racist
and that's sad but i encourage you to
listen to this entire segment all the
way through
i've been telling you all along that
when joe biden does things that i don't
like
or that fail to be truly left i'm going
to point them out to you
i'm going to call them out and we have
the perfect prototypical example today
president-elect joe biden has selected
lloyd austin to be a secretary of
defense
lloyd austin is a retired four-star army
general
was previously the commander of centcom
actually was the first
african-american commander of centcom
and would be the first
african-american secretary of defense in
american history
very interesting personal story from
alabama
raised in georgia graduated from west
point two master's degrees including an
mba
really interesting guy no shortage of
intelligence no shortage of military and
other experience and academic experience
no doubt whatsoever but this is the
perfect example
of how a lot of people are focusing on
the identity story
at the exclusion of admitting and
recognizing that lloyd austin
as interesting as his career has been as
inspiring as i admit
being the first black secretary of
defense would be
lloyd austin represents exactly the
problems we're trying to fix
in government and in foreign policy and
in defense
lloyd austin is the prototypical example
of diversification in terms of identity
without changing any of the power
structures
which partially are responsible for the
problems that make his identity as the
first black secretary of defense
notable in the first place to start with
this is another
military guy who hasn't even been out of
the military long enough
seven years such that he requires a
congressional exemption to even be
allowed to be secretary of defense
let me explain that many people may not
know about this
there's a law the national security act
of 1947
which requires any prospective cabinet
secretary
to wait seven full years after ending
active duty in the military as a
commissioned officer
before you can be in a president's
cabinet lloyd austin was on
active duty until 2016. now i am not
going to be a hypocrite
i remember that back in 2017
i did a story about donald trump's
secretary of defense selection
jim mattis uh at the time the the title
of this video was these democrats
plus one republican had the balls to
vote no on trump cabinet now the title
doesn't tell you about what's in the
story
but in that story i explained jim mattis
trump's pick for secretary of defense
hasn't been out of active duty for seven
years
so congress is going to need to issue a
waiver to get jim mattis
in donald trump's cabinet and at the
time i said
why the hell do we have a rule about
this if the president can just go to
congress and get a waiver
and i'm not a hypocrite so i have to
tell you the exact same thing today
if we have this rule from 1947
why not stick to it what is the point if
joe biden can just get it waived
why do we need such a recent active duty
military person as secretary of defense
because the rule was meant to
disincentivize choosing
recent active duty military people
instead of choosing long-retired
military folks
or straight-up civilians for secretary
of defense the idea
being non-military secretaries of
defense
or or those who have a military
background but have been out of the
military longer
would be less cozy with the military and
they would bring
a more uh uh impartial approach
to sort of counterbalance the joint
chiefs of staff
and others within the military that's
the whole point here so
this was a great opportunity for joe
biden to instead of starting with
another military officer who's was was
in the military so recently that he's
got to be waved in
joe biden could have started his
presidency with a return to normalcy
with civilian oversight of military
plans and actions
but he's the first black secretary of
defense that
is the story that is being told and then
on the other side of this
you're also putting a ton of democrats
in a really stupid looking position
because many democrats who will vote on
this
nomination opposed the waiver
for jim mattis in 2017 now
they are likely going to have to
acquiesce and okay
lloyd austin and this applies to those
uh in the house of representatives as
well
confirming that they are hypocrites and
giving republicans more ammunition than
we need to give them to quote joe biden
come on man
this is misguided and then when you look
specifically at lloyd austin's military
career
it's not good lloyd austin was the
commanding general
in iraq and then commander of us central
command centcom
in the u.s withdrawal in 2011 the
subsequent collapse of the iraqi army in
2012 to isis
so now look at the big picture not only
are you having to wave in a guy too
recently in the military to be
traditionally eligible
you have a guy who during his
confirmation hearings
is going to be on the receiving end of
legitimate
criticisms for how he handled iraq as
well
so sadly there are people who are going
to listen to my entire story
and they're going to say david that's
racist you don't want a black secretary
of defense no
that's not what i said if you're going
to eve don't even email me
that don't even bother emailing me that
and unfortunately
we will lose subscribers we will lose
paid members because i did this story
because some people will not focus on
what i'm actually criticizing here
which is that we are diversifying in
terms of identity
but perpetuating the exact problems
that we've been pointing out for more
than a decade at this point in time so
so far near a tandem disastrous pick
uh lloyd austin very problematic for the
reasons that i mentioned these strike me
as unforced
errors if i'm missing something about
this pick
let me know we'll have more coverage of
this on our instagram
at david pakman show and um i
look forward to hearing your thoughts
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration
and they're giving you 25 off your first
order it's made with four key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
we are welcoming back today a longtime
friend of the show
benjamin dixon host of the benjamin
dixon show
resident of the all-important state of
georgia
we are going to talk about what already
happened in georgia what may happen on
january 5th ben it's so good to see you
david it's always good to see you and
good to be back here sharing with your
channel congratulations on the million
subscribers oh thank you million one
million two now right well listen you're
going to get there faster than i did
it'll you're not there yet but uh you're
you're compressing my growth into
less time i'm sure i certainly hope so
man because
it already feels like it's been forever
it's been like six years so uh but we're
just still doing the work and excited
about what's happening in georgia
yeah so i mean let's just dive right
into it first of all
you know there were questions will texas
go red i never i'm sorry will texas go
blue i never thought it would
what's going to happen in florida i
thought it was kind of a question mark
i i did not think georgia was the most
likely
to go to joe biden but it did you
followed it in a way that that i didn't
from outside of the state were you
surprised
right no i wasn't i was pleased i was
thoroughly pleased but i knew
the kind of work that was happening on
the ground i knew the type of
registrations that were happening
um the new georgia project which is
affiliated with stacey abrams
and a couple of other colleagues of mine
new georgia project registered
half a million people of color alone in
this cycle
and so with those kind of numbers
and the type of targeted push that i saw
on the ground i suspected that georgia
would be blue
i just didn't want to jinx it so i kept
my fingers crossed
so we've got these two senate races
and john ossoff david perdue there's no
more debates there
um i i almost had to call atlanta police
and report a murder after that first
debate with assaf and perdue i mean
that's one of the most brutal debates
i've ever seen and i understand why
david perdue's not debating
we had the leftler warnock debate on
sunday
and she seemed to have a software
malfunction where she was repeating the
same five things over and over including
the word uh socialist and a radical
leftist radical liberal raphael warnock
my instinct and my audience was this is
so transparent
but we don't necessarily understand the
totality of the electorate in georgia
is that type of repetition actually
something that could win you a senate
race in georgia
no no but what can win u.s interest in
georgia is simply
being complicit and part and parcel with
the power structure that kelly lefler
represents and what she's trying to
protect so
they don't care how incompetent she is
she's theirs she's that's that's their
con that's their senator that's the
person
who they're going to vote for i mean
they voted for donald trump right
i know joe biden won but there's still a
lot of people in georgia who support
trumpism so
um do they support her malfunction
because she did have a software
malfunction to be sure
no they probably think she's she's bland
as a borg
uh but they're still gonna vote for her
and in terms of voting
at all and this is something that i am
just fascinated by
on the one hand early it was its rigged
rigged rig
trump really won etc which would imply
january 5th could maybe is also rigged
and then you started seeing inklings of
this
let's just boycott republicans boycott
if they're not going to count our votes
anyway let's just boycott
which of course is crazy because that
will just hand the wins to to the two
democratic candidates
but lately in trump's rally during the
debate you saw lefler say it
they're now focusing on the importance
of getting out every vote do you think
that this boycott movement will have any
impact
well i i will say that the republicans
here in the state of georgia
are pretty much like the republicans
across the country
they they're doing their best to hold it
together
while they figure out what the hell to
do with donald trump and
that's happening in georgia so people
don't really know republicans don't
really know whether they are free to
distance themselves from donald trump
nobody is going to attack him
but they are afraid to distance
themselves and so there's kind of a
kerfuffle right
there's confusion there's chaos there's
dissent in uh georgia republicans we see
some of them just
uh uh disagreeing with each other
publicly they're going in different
directions in terms of strategy
um i i think they are collapsing under
the weight of donald trump's ego
and i think that's going to have a huge
effect in january and so but but as far
as just like this idea of them staying
home
as some kind of solidarity with the
claims right it was rigged
only a few percent need to do that for
it to potentially make a difference
given how close it's expected to be
right because the uh special elections
the the uh special elections on january
5th
the turnout is going to be by definition
lower right it's a special election
and so the margins are going to be that
much more important so if they actually
do
manage to get like one percent even just
one percent of georgia's turnout
uh republican turnout to stay home um
then that could be the margin of
difference here
i've been having not really an argument
but kind of a disagreement about
strategy with some in my audience where
last week i said listen
for 10 years on this program i've been
saying increase
civic engagement voting is is a it's
step one it's only step one but it is
step one
increased turnout overall the left does
better with more turnout
and so i would not feel okay saying
hey republicans you know you really
should stay home you really should
boycott this thing because i feel like
at a higher level it's not what i'm
about
now some people in my audience wrote to
me and they said listen david if
democrats take the senate and kamala
harris becomes the tie-breaking vote
things will get done that would not
otherwise get done
the country will be better off isn't
there some greater good in just this one
time
encouraging republicans not to vote even
if you have to lie to them about the rig
stuff i can't get behind that
like i i'm having a lot of trouble with
that what's your
thought on this this idea no no no it's
a great question because i'm actually uh
i'm senior advisor for really american
and they are running some really
provocative ads in
georgia billboards particularly they
have billboards all over the state
um uh that are basically basically
encouraging republicans to continue
fighting each other
right and and in a way if you're not
careful it could have
a suppressive effect against republicans
because
if republicans feel like they have a lot
of infighting they're more likely to
stay home
i'm okay with that um i and i 100
understand where you come from
david and and i find myself struggling
with that on a regular basis well let me
clarify ben just to be make sure i know
what you're saying
you're saying you're okay i'm okay with
them staying home if they want to
convince each other to stay home
that's great i'm not gonna say you know
you really should vote where i
sort of draw the line is participating
in the encouragement
to stay home because it's rigged well
we're participating in what um
uh my colleague at really american calls
a truth-telling campaign
okay watch watch the spin yeah it was a
great spin so
he said all we're doing is telling the
truth about what's going on in the
georgia republican party
i think the people of georgia have the
right to understand the divisions that
are happening in the republican party so
uh we're calling what we're doing a
truth-telling campaign and and you know
i know
you know we can read between the lines
we want to win georgia and
then um you guys could you know people
who disagree with me not you
particularly uh but y'all could come
after us afterwards we're gonna we're
gonna win this race
and uh and then and then we'll feel bad
about what we did afterwards
so you're confident about the the two uh
races
i i'm i'm pretty uh i'm pretty bullish
on it i feel um
i feel that if everything falls in place
we could pull out a miracle it will be a
miracle right it's not going to be easy
but i think all the elements are in
place and i think if everyone plays
their cards right we can get two seats
and i know that's a stretch
but i'm willing to just to go out on the
limb there
let's talk a little bit about the
incoming
biden administration uh i said
months ago i will call it the way i see
it if i see joe biden pick people that i
think are problematic i will tell you it
won't mean that i think i should have
voted for trump instead it will just
mean i voted for the right person but
they made some selections i didn't like
so far the two that i am concerned about
primarily are nira tandon um absolutely
and lloyd austin and you know uh back in
2017 i said when jim mattis was selected
uh guys
we we have a rule about being out of the
military seven years
so what's the point of the rule if you
can just get a congressional waiver and
get around that there's a reason that
that rule is in place
the exact same waiver is going to be
necessary for lloyd austin
and i would be a hypocrite if i didn't
call it out he was involved in some of
the mishandling
of of the iraq war in 2011 and in 2014.
this this is not a pick i love and to me
it strikes me
as identity diversification
without solving the structural problems
right right well i mean so there's
always going to be david there's there's
always going to be an
element in the corporate democratic wing
that is more than happy to give us
uh identity um you know it could because
it is it is a
it is it instantly celebrated that this
is a black guy who's going to lead the
pentagon right with lloyd austin
yep um but you know we just take a break
and breathe and look and say oh well
this is that guy
and so i think it's um you know that's
our job
our job is going to be to maneuver
through the bs of them using identity
uh as a shield like i think identity
politics matters i want to make sure i
say that i think identity politics
matters
because black people and and all kind of
identities suffer
identity specific problems in this
country there are problems that black
people go through simply because they
are black
lgbtqia obviously however when the
corporate democrats use it as a shield
against criticism
we have to be able to maneuver through
that and still bring a solid critique
against their uh their corporate
their corporatism and imperialism right
the phrase i've used is
i value identity because of the insight
it gives us
but where i stop is whether it's used as
either a shield
or a cudgel to or a mallet to beat
people sort of over the head
and that's where the rational thinking
seems to go out right
well i mean and i agree with you i agree
with you all the way to the point where
i think that there are some situations
in this country that require a mallet to
the head
i think that there are some very
stubborn situations
in this country that are so intrinsic
and malignant to be quite honest
like racism is malignant in this country
and and if we need to go
straight head to head with it then fine
but we have to be able to understand
when
it's time to recognize how identity
politics just like any i mean
any other politics are used against you
for powerful people to continue
getting their way into getting their
agenda and we just have to know when
that's happening with identity
yeah and interestingly it's i mean it's
good you mentioned that because
oftentimes
class politicking is also used in ways
that but it's just not identified as
pernicious
and with the phrase oh identity politics
is being used
you rarely hear that said about class
politics but it's used very frequently
yeah yeah and see class politics is an
identity politics that i get down with
i'm like
i'm down with like four flat tires with
class politics as well as race racial
politics
uh but i agree with you right it is if
you're not careful there's an element of
a class critique
that itself can become a cudgel it could
become a bludgeoning tool it could
become
uh a weaponized um way to ignore logic
and reason right um so we just have to
be careful that anything that we really
believe in can be weaponized against us
uh if we're if we if we give it a free
pass and not or
and we're not willing to critique it
truthfully and in good faith
so who do you like that joe biden has
selected so far
um
nobody nobody no no i'm serious i'm
really trying to think of any uh
cedric i forget cedric's last name
congressman um who had that
brilliant exchange with matt gates about
his son i can't think of cedric's love
for last name but he he's okay i don't
i'm honestly i'm not excited about any
of his picks
i am what i have decided to do with joe
biden is to
let him make his play let him make his
play i can't control who he picks no
matter how much commentary we give we
can't control who he picks
but we can decide what type of uh
opponent we have in the white house
is the opponent that we have to oppose
with all of our energy or is the
opponent that we need to uh keep an eye
on because he made some bad picks and we
need to keep an eye on what they're
going to do
i think he's going to fall into that
ladder category yeah i mean i i've said
that i i dug back into
some of uh janet yellen's economic
writing from the 90s which where she was
like an academic uh
economist she's she's pretty brilliant
and i mean it's like listen she's gonna
she's gonna run
the the treasury and um she believes in
monetary policy you know like that that
we would expect that joe biden's going
going to pick somebody like that
but uh things like her fair wage
hypothesis from 1990 which i would
definitely check out if you've not read
it yeah
very very interesting stuff she is quite
brilliant and
at least i think she will not stand in
the way
if joe biden can otherwise get consensus
and political
capital to get things done i don't think
she'll stand in the way of anything he's
he campaigned on whether he'll do it is
a different question yeah and i think
that's that is the million-dollar
question right so what does
joe biden really want to do right the
rest of this is on the periphery
right he's going to do a lot of things
because there's a lot of people in a lot
of departments who have their own
agendas
and he's going to filter through them
and they'll get whatever their agenda is
done
right which is why i'm really leery
about the possibility of rahm emanuel
because i just kind of
have a feeling i know what this guy
wants and it's never been anything good
for black people or poor people
that said uh with everyone else joe
biden is picking
i want to see what joe biden actually
wants because what he actually wants is
what he's going to put his energy behind
david i'm afraid that what he really
wants is bipartisanship with republicans
i think his end-all goal might be
bipartisanship
and then then that is somebody i have to
take a pretty good stand against but
yeah that's completely naive
i mean that's just totally elected
though i'm still glad we elected him of
course
yeah no but the idea that you're going
to get things done with the help of this
republican party
it it seems like the height of naivete
yes
yes and and i don't know if joe biden i
think possibly with joe biden it could
be sincere naivete
i think with people around him who
always triangulate with republicans i
think
it is intentional because they probably
identify with republicans more than they
they do progressives but with joe biden
i don't know the jury is still out i
think he actually believes that
bipartisanship
is the greater good yeah we will uh i
think we'll know relatively quickly is
the upside i think by march 1st we'll
have a pretty good sense of whether he
he really believes that
ben dixon the benjamin dixon show so
you've got the audio podcast
yes you've got the facebook and the
youtube channel
and you seem to have like a dozen
ancillary shows that i
regularly am catching streams of so like
what what's the
the hub where people can what's the best
place i mean you know what they honestly
can go to the youtube channel right here
on youtube subscribe on youtube
um uh give us a please sir can we have
some more some
of your subscribers david can we have
some more of your subscribers you know
the beautiful thing about youtube
subscribers is
like when me and when sam cedar and i
were having this fake war to a million
yeah it's not zero sum it's not you have
one subscribe subscription and you
either give it
to sam or to banner to david you can
generate
subscriptions infinitely just by
subscribing to more than one channel so
i always say
spread the wealth around hey man i
appreciate that see that's where i rock
with david and david for everyone who
doesn't know
david has been rocking with my show
since i started my show like maybe
six months after i started my show david
contacted me so man i appreciate
everything that you've done to help me
on this journey
my my pleasure and um let's let's do it
again very soon sounds good take care
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i have something very special for you
today yes
this is another one of those going down
with the ship
appearances by donald trump's press
secretary kelly mckennery on fox news
uh propaganda sean hannity's program yes
kaylee is still pushing debunked voter
fraud claims
that no court believes that they have no
evidence for that even donald trump
seems to have given up on at this point
but this clip is special in that it has
an extra element that is really
dangerous and particularly pernicious it
shows us how lack of
just simple mathematical understanding
can be used by people
whether they understand it or not to
trick others
into believing really stupid things
donald trump's press secretary
kaley mckenney in this appearance last
night did some of the typical things for
example as usual
she holds up pieces of paper as if
holding up pieces of paper makes her
claims more credible take a look
this is significant which is why you
have 18 states
signing on to this very well done
lawsuit by the state of texas
and then she holds up pieces of paper
again
as if they change anything about the
fact that donald trump lost
and joe biden won power and because jake
tapper fake new cnn and others
can't wake up and find enough energy to
go read a public court filing i i did it
for them
you can find the sworn declaration
by charles caschetti who by the way ph.d
from rutgers
tenured professor expert testimony in
hundreds of court cases
goes through meticulously how he used z
scores and standard deviations from a
medium to come up with this
median to come up with this number so
it's the job of a reporter to go find
this
it's out there it's public and it's a
dereliction of the duty and the job that
each of these reporters have
to not look into this to not look at the
sourcing which is available for all to
read
sworn declaration whoa hold on a second
here oh wait a second joe biden still
won
right so that's all the stuff we're used
to
but then here comes the dangerous math
take a look at this kaylee mckennany
presents the idea
that what took place on election night
has only a
one in one quadrillion chance of
happening and thus
there must have been fraud donald trump
must have won now one quadrillion
is a thousand raised to the power of
five
or 1 followed by 15
zeros sean hannity asks her kaylee
how did you come up with that number and
she explains
but explain how you got that number
yeah i'm glad you asked that because you
had fake news cnn saying that the
affidavits i were showing were blank
when all you had to do was go look at a
public court filing to read them
yourselves but of course they couldn't
do that that's the job of a reporter but
instead i'm having to do their job
for them including with this number uh
the stat i gave last night which is
eye-opening and truthful is that
for for president trump to be ahead as
far as he was at 3am
in these four states michigan
pennsylvania wisconsin georgia
and for the vote to swing by as much as
it did the
probability of that in one state is one
and one quadrillion
that's one comma 15 zeros uh to happen
in all four
it's one comma fifteen zeros to the
fourth power and because
jake tapper fake new cnn and others
can't uh wake up and find enough energy
to go read a public court filing i i did
it for them
so the this this the claim is so we have
to first understand the claim
and then we can we can better examine it
what she says
is the odds of what happened in some
states when they counted ballots meaning
trump was winning and then he was losing
as they counted more ballots
she says the odds of that happening in
one state
are one in one quadrillion and then she
says
and because it happened in four states
the odds of that happening in four
states are one in one quadrillion raised
to the fourth power so let's deal with
the second part first because it's
simpler eric
one of our viewers eric wrote to me and
and said david
do you think she doesn't realize that
that's not how exponents work or do you
think she realizes it and is just lying
to people i have no idea but
eric is right if the odds were one in
one quadrillion in one state
you don't just raise that to the fourth
power to calculate the odds of it
happening in four states the math
doesn't work that way
now let me explain to you what they're
what they're trying to do here and it
can be really tough to explain this
stuff
i uh this will be a nice challenge let's
see if i can explain this in a way
that's clear
in pennsylvania the final election
results
were biden 50 and trump
48.8 percent let's just call it for
simplicity 50 to 49
okay now what this one in one
quadrillion thing comes from
is imagine for a second that
the results within any
slice of pennsylvania were
the same or expected to be the same as
for the entire state so what i mean by
that is
joe biden won pennsylvania 50-49
if you expected joe biden to win every
county
50-49 and you expected joe biden to win
every city
50-49 and you expected joe biden to win
in-person voting 50-49 and mail in
voting by 50-49
only if you assume identical
distribution of votes
in all locations and all types of votes
only
then would you be able to say the odds
of
trump having a hundred thousand several
hundred thousand vote lead on election
night
and that lead evaporating as mail-in
ballots are counted
would be very very unlikely but we know
that that's not the case
for example in philadelphia biden got 81
percent of the vote
trump only got 18. and in philadelphia
there were more than 700 000 votes
on the other hand if you look at as an
example clearfield county
pennsylvania trump easily won clearfield
county with 74 percent of the vote but
it's a very small number of voters it's
only 40 thousand compared to
seven hundred thousand in philadelphia
if you look at in person
versus mailing in-person voting was much
more
skewed to donald trump mail-in voting
was much more skewed to joe biden
exactly as expected so
one quadrillion one in one quadrillion
is
meaningless once you realize low
population red areas where there was
more in-person voting
those were counted early and they leaned
trump
high population biden areas with more
male in voting were counted late
both of which we anticipated it's not
like that's even a surprise and once you
understand that
kaylee's saying one in one quadrillion
is instantly nonsense it's just
meaningless
but it sounds good to lots of people who
don't understand basic math
and then of course raise it to the
fourth power because we're talking about
four states that's also garbage
that's just trash so this exemplifies
how trumpists get
into much of this nonsense they they
fall for bogus math
i don't know if kaley knows that the
math is garbage
and she's lying or maybe kaylee doesn't
even understand the math doesn't really
matter
the point is kaylee gives a big number
and she used exponents
so that must mean that donald trump
actually won this election and of course
that's garbage
and uh this is a prime example of how
people fall for this stuff
this next story reminds us that it's not
always that elites don't care that the
average american can't always afford
health care
or housing payments or food sometimes
they may not know
what's going on and as some of you may
know
donald trump's lawyer rudy giuliani has
been hospitalized with covid for a few
days
rudy behaved completely irresponsibly
for the last month he's been flying
around the country
doing indoor so-called voter fraud
hearings no mask
so he caught the virus a trump lawyer
jenna ellis
also caught the virus rudy was
reportedly convinced
by donald trump's doctor sean connelly
go to the hospital just go
go go because reportedly sean connelly
said to rudy we can deal with this in
three days and then you'll be good to go
and then from the hospital earlier this
week
rudy was speaking out against masks and
social distancing guidelines i mean the
irony
while he's in a hospital getting
treatment and we later found out rudy
giuliani received remdesseviere
and dexamethasone as treatment rudy was
interviewed on new york talk radio
station 77 wabc
and he said listen we have treatments
this is okay
listen they give you medications and you
improve let's not overreact
let's not go crazy with masks and social
distancing and when the host pointed out
you know
the protocol you've received in
particular room deserver
except in certain cases where you
qualify for it without paying
that's too expensive for most americans
every american can't get from deservier
and rudy said oh
well i don't know i mean you know they
gave it to me here at this hospital
and he said i don't know that it's true
that not everybody can get this
when trump came out of coronavirus he
was also saying
don't these are quotes don't be afraid
of it
don't let it dominate your life we have
treatments it might even be a cure
and of course donald trump received
dexamethasone for low oxygen
which is not expensive but again you
have to be in a place where you're being
monitored very closely where as soon as
you get low oxygen you get the decks
he got five days of room deserve trump
got the experimental antibody treatment
from regeneron
this is not available to all patients
it's available to rich
and or privileged patients or celebrity
patients
so rudy is thinking i don't know i got
this
i just went to the hospital i've got a
three doctor team
monitoring me and the top treatments
what's the big deal
and this is exactly the point people
connected to reality
understand that this is a two-tiered
system in the united states now
rudy did say he doesn't think he would
even have
gone to the hospital this soon were he
not well known or a celebrity so
he in that same interview he seemed to
recognize
you know they i think i'm here because
i'm a celebrity i don't know that that i
would even be here
but he's unaware of the fact that even
when hospitalized
not everybody can get the treatment that
he got and and this is the reality
american health care is really good for
the privileged and the wealthy people
even come from other countries
here to get specific treatments or
procedures even for people living in one
part of the country versus another
it can be a significantly better
healthcare system but for huge
swaths of the population it's a
disastrous
system um at the same time
uh you know again i
he rudy acknowledges he's there because
he's a celebrity but he seems to think
anybody anybody would get
to get the treatment most people are
told stay home
if it gets really bad come in when you
go in it's packed
and you have one doctor for 20 patients
rather than three doctors
for one celebrity patient now it's quite
possible
that even if rudy giuliani knew that not
everybody could get the same treatment
he still might not have a different
perspective on what should be done
but this is like the height of of
plutocracy it's less that
you know i have no problem with rudy
getting what he's getting
it's that everybody should be able to
get it and they can't from desevere it
would even be a dosing issue i mean
there's not that much of it available
and rudy seems completely clueless about
that piece of it folks like rudy don't
understand
what these things cost whether the
average american can afford it
think back to my appendectomy last year
i have insurance with a two thousand
dollar
annual deductible for hospitalization
large procedures er that type of thing
so
when i went in not even knowing yet that
i had appendicitis but suspecting it
i knew i could be responsible for up to
two thousand bucks i could come out
hours later
and owe two thousand dollars and when
they started with the ct scan
and the iv drips and then said you have
appendicitis you're having surgery
i anticipated i'm gonna owe two grand
here now
i always have in my mind i have a two
thousand dollar deductible
at any time i fall and break an ankle or
i get
whatever i could owe two thousand
dollars i have the two thousand dollars
it's okay i had the privilege of knowing
you know what
i'll go to a top hospital brigham and
women's have a great surgeon
great care and then i'll owe two grand
and then i'll pay for it and that's
great
half the country can't meet an
unexpected 400 expense
with insurance they would not be able to
meet
the deductible and my deductible isn't
even that high lots of folks
with high deductible plans might have a
four five six or seven thousand dollar
deductible to meet
before their insurance kicks in and
meanwhile rudy thinks
you show up they give you the decks they
give you room deserve three doctors are
checking in on me and it's all really
really great
this is part of the problem a lot of the
people claiming it's no big deal are the
people who have access to that
at the drop of a pin we have a voicemail
number
that number is 2192 david p
here's a question that you i i don't
know the implication
from the caller but it's actually a
really good question which we talked
about last week on the show about what
is
safe in the context of the virus take a
listen hey david this is christian
from louisiana right i was just
wondering
it i find it uh kind of suspicious that
during this covet pandemic all these
big big box retailers have been allowed
to
you know let almost full capacity
in at all times while small businesses
are reduced to
you know 15 percent in california or 50
in other places
do you think that there's a connection
in this because
all the money that comes to the you know
the senate in the house
and to all these politicians from these
big box retailers
and that they have a vested interest in
keeping their stores open listen i i
don't know about the money piece
but scott atlas recently brought this up
the radiologist that trump had working
for him for a while he also said
why is it that a full capacity big box
store is safe
and a small restaurant at half capacity
is not and you know what i agree with
him
the thing is the conclusion may be
different i don't think the big box
store at full capacity is safe and we
have a report from el paso texas which
actually finds
that a huge amount of the contagion is
happening
in the big box stores now i don't know
exactly what sort of mask wearing
requirements are enforced
uh in el paso texas in big box stores
and certainly
the wearing of masks would reduce the
transmission
but this is a perfectly reasonable
question except for me the answer isn't
open up restaurants at full capacity
which are
very you know smaller lower ceilings
less sophisticated ventilation in many
cases
etc it's i don't think the full capacity
big box stores make any sense whatsoever
so a very reasonable question
which i've been asking as well but i
think we need to understand
which side is the answer we should be
leaning towards
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about the san francisco
apartment building smoking ban very
interesting news there
we will talk about hunter biden
shockingly we actually have something to
talk about now
related to hunter and we will also talk
about allegations about a friend of the
david pakman show congressman eric
swalwell
all of those stories on today's bonus
show get instant access by
signing up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman hydrant
is the delicious fruit drink powder
packed with essential electrolytes for
hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman